when you lose confidence in yourself
which you will by not having a routine
and breaking little tiny promises to
yourself um now you can't exude
confidence and authenticity to the
outside world and you pay a price for
that work ethic starts to boil down to
how do I actually manage my days like
how do I actually get up in the morning
get something rolling and do this 365
days a year or whatever the pattern is
over that time to have any success in
any event field you have to be
disciplined and you have to have routine
I call them rituals things that I repeat
every day that feel comfortable to me
that don't feel like they're just boring
habits but they're kind of comforting